roger karoutchi en avion et leur fils
consultait les parlementaires est ce que
ces parlementaires ont vraiment leur mot
à dire où ce ne sont que des
consultations de façade
je suis assez inquiet parce que pas très
franc le cadre même de la réforme
constitutionnelle ou ce qu'on veut
mettre à l'intérieur de cette réforme
ça a beaucoup changé en trois quatre
mois parce que j'entends bien monsieur
castaner dire il ya des engagements du
président de la république
franchement je paul sentiment que
pendant la campagne présidentielle ou
même dans son discours devant le congrès
du parlement le président la république
est abordé la réduction du droit
d'amendement l'inscription de la corse
dans la constitution
les trois mandats il a abordé la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires et
la thur on est prêts à discuter mais sur
le reste chaque semaine nous apporte des
éléments nouveaux
où on se dit qu'est ce qu'ils veulent on
veulent t'ils aller on a fait la réforme
de 2008
j'en sais quelque chose pour la voir en
grande partie conduite pour renforcer
les pouvoirs du parlement et c'était la
volonté de nicolas sarkozy d'avoir un
équilibre entre l'exécutif fort sous la
vème république et un parlement ayant
quand même capacité d'intervention
là on a le sentiment que sous couvert de
réformer les pouvoirs on veut en réalité
neutraliser le parler vous vous demandez
quoi concrètement quels sont vos lignes
rouges sur quels points pris cela il ya
plusieurs lignes rouges
là nous nous avons déjà dit que nous
comprenions pas par exemple
l'inscription de la corse dans la
constitution ou jeu je suis pour qu'on
avance sur un certain nombre de voix par
m et par un article spécifique comme ce
qui est envisagé par les arédiens parce
que ça ouvre la voie à d'autres et dans
quelles conditions et qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
donc on l'avait refusée en 2008 qui a vu
un débat rappelez-vous rinck sur
l'inscription des langues régionales à
vous imaginer carrément une collectivité
donc ça c'est un peu compliqué deuxième
élément on est prêt à discuter de la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires à
condition déjà de savoir comment la
proportionnelle c'est pas franchement
notre tasse de thé et on était prêt si
c'était vraiment marginale ça ne se
remettait pas en cause les équilibres du
scrutin mais quand j'entends qu'on est à
15 20 voire 25 % alors là vous casser le
6 est déposé et ckoi marginal
quel est le seuil que vous pouvez
activer en 10 % public venait à 400
députés et 6,10 à 32 40 sièges à la
proportionnelle
on me dit pour franchement ça me casse
les pieds parce que moi je suis un
défenseur du scrutin majoritaire mais on
peut regarder s'il faut vraiment faire
en sorte que toutes les parties y
compris ceux qui au scrutin majoritaire
ne serait pas représentée puisse l'être
mais de là à dire que ça devait un
élément fort de la composition
l'assemblée nationale non et enfin sur
les trois mandats successifs
on ne sait toujours rien c'est
interactif ou pas c'est ça concerne les
fonctionnaires ionale les fonctions
locales qui aujourd'hui qui aujourd'hui
dans ce pays qui a un maire qui a été
élu parce qu'on rénove beaucoup qui est
un maître des lieux à 30 ans s'il est
content de son maire qui va dire au
maire écoutez monsieur l'effet trop
grande à au revoir vous êtes en plein
dans vos investissements on veut pas
savoir c'est sur la lune rousse est
libre choix des électeurs de choisir
quand même c'est le minimum dans un pays
démocratique et respectant les droits du
parlement
j'ai bien entendu ce que disait le
groupe communiste je partage entièrement
le droit d'amendement c'est un droit
individuel on va juste une question vous
dites il ya des lignes rouges mais vous
êtes quand même prêt à négocier sur
certains points est-ce que vous pensez
que l'exécutif est lui aussi disposé à
lâcher du lest le président larcher a
beaucoup discuté et sincèrement ici ou
là des parlementaires ont eu des
contacts avec matignon et de l'elysée
pour faire avancer les choses
ce qui me laisse un peu pantois pardon
de le dire comme ça mais c'est pas le
seul sujet la révision constitutionnelle
sur lequel on semble de temps en temps
avoir ça c'est que de semaine en semaine
on rajoute des points
par exemple le droit d'amendement
personne ne l'évoqué jusqu'à ya quinze
jours donc ça ou alors c'est qu'ils
veulent pas d'accord et que s'ouvrent
les discussions négociations pour donner
le sentiment de consulter mais qu'au
bout du bout soit ils veulent passer en
force
soit ils voudraient un référendum bien
risqué et je reçois du bruit est ce que
vous avez aussi l'impression que le
sentiment qu emmanuel macron cherche à
faire le procès en conservatisme du
sénat sur cette réforme
oui parce que c'est le procès le plus
facile il
de tradition depuis 20 ans on dit la
deuxième chambre
c'est représente trop les notables elle
bloque le système et tout c'est un faux
procès tout le monde le sait puisque le
bicamérisme fonctionne plutôt bien moi
j'ai beaucoup d'amis députés qui disent
heureusement que le sénat corrige
souvent les textes de lois qu'on leur
envoie et ils ont raison le bicamérisme
c'est la capacité de faire de bonnes
lois
alors après qu'il faille un travail
parlementaire plus lyon plus rapide
moi je suis d'accord mais c'est pas ça
qui est l'objectif visiblement alors le
président de l'assemblée françois de
rugy l'ue espère qu'un compromis sera
trouvé avec le sénat et sinon place au
référendum écoutez je dialogue d'ores et
déjà depuis plusieurs semaines avec le
président du sénat pour que nous
puissions arriver d'ici l'été à jean
n'en doute pas un texte commun qui
permettra d'avoir une réforme de la
constitution adoptée par le parlement
si jamais il y avait des blocages le
président de la république l'a dit le
gouvernement l'envisagent
il peut toujours y avoir un référendum
sur quelques points
est ce que vous pensez qu'au final le
présent rappel va recourir à l'armé du
référendum
franchement je lui déconseille je suis
pas là pour dire au peuple qu'il a à
faire mais d'abord qu'il réfléchisse
bien ce qui se passe lorsque matteo
renzi en italie a voulu faire un
référendum sur les institutions il se
croyait à l'époque très puissant l'échec
du référendum a marqué le début de la
fin de matteo renzi beaucoup plus rapide
que prévu on se lance pas dans un
référendum institutionnel sans ceinture
et bretelles et donc là moi je vous
passe les bretelles et que la ceinture
et mal bouclée parce que à force de
vouloir mettre beaucoup de choses dans
le référendum
vous n'allez pas mettre un fin d'hommes
uniquement la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires ça c'est très populaire
monsieur organique suffit pourquoi le à
la révision constitutionnelle fait le
voter en poche et la mise en disant
voyez gérer du nombre de parlementaires
tout le monde est content macron nous
aussi la négocier sur les correct bon
voilà mais faire un référendum où vous
allez mettre la corse
nombre de parlementaires les trois
mandats
le pouvoir d'amendement attention
attention de ne pas avoir au fur et à
mesure des jours qui passent là le
conglomérat des opposants qui sont pas
forcément sur la constitution mais qui
pourrait donner un verdict négatif alors
sur ce droit d'amendement puisque vous
en parlez roger karoutchi le droit
d'amendement c'est un souhait d'edouard
philippe 1 soit un petit peu surprise
cette semaine de restreindre le droit
d'amendement parlementaire en le
conditionnant au nombre d'élus par
groupe
est ce que ce n'est quand même pas
logique de tenir compte de la
représentativité des groupes selon vous
non et franchement moins 2008 dans la
réforme
on a essayer d'encadrer le droit
d'amendement parce qu'on voulait à
l'époque essayait de faire en sorte que
les amendements par exemple présenté en
commission ne puisse pas l'être
forcément à nouveau en séance plénière
ce qui ralentit le débat mais il était
question jusque juste d'un encadrement
la vision du gouvernement et d'edouard
philippe 6 il la maintient sur il ya
plus de droits individuels en réalité
d'amendements mais c'est un droit
collectif de groupe
c'est une vision totalement inacceptable
totalement inacceptable parce que ça
veut dire en gros que le parlementaire
lui-même n'existe pas il n'existe qu'au
travers de sa serai piétiner ça veut
dire ça veut dire surtout que à court
moyen terme
tous les députés seront élus au système
proportionnel par les parties vous
revenez au système des partis
vous n'êtes pas dans un grand parti vous
ne pouvez pas influé sur le débat
parlementaire c'est une aberration enfin
css et constitutionnel non non en 2008
le conseil constitutionnel nous avait
dit que le simple encadrement papa pas
limité par go pain mais l'encadrement
c'est à dire le fait de pas pouvoir
représenter un amendement n'était pas
acceptable
comment est ce que le conseil
constitutionnel pourra accepter que en
réalité les parlementaires perdent leur
droit d'amendement individuel c'est
impossible